[Music]
hello everyone Perry here with another
interview in Park City we are at the Kia
supper sweepit thanks to Kia for making
these interviews happen right now we're
talking about the movie spree with the
folks behind the film oh my this is one
heck of a ride just in case our viewers
do not know what spree is I got to do it
to you can you please give a brief
synopsis of the film spree is a story of
a rideshare driver named Kirkland Cole
played by mr. Joe Keary who is desperate
for social media attention a big
following and he comes up with a
demented scheme to get it which is
should I tell them what it is oh please
do I was I also want to see how far you
go with the synopsis so I know when to
stop my questions it's just it's just a
twisted live stream let's say that very
tuned in find out where did the whole
thing start for you was it you know the
commentary on social media and
influencers was it like a bad rumor I
don't know yeah no well it was sort of
this idea that that's a perfect sort of
like theatrical space for attention and
drama which is the being stuck in a
rideshare but really was really clicked
was like wow it's um we're at this
moment where our identities and our
self-worth is so much revolving around
validation on social media and how
twisted that feels and just think about
what the worst case scenario for someone
trying to you know reach for that could
be you know what is the most horrific
scenario yeah we got it
but it's grounded in this relatability
that we all sort of feel like oh you
know if we just want to get the likes
and the clout because otherwise how
would anybody else know we exist through
human interaction like what is that I
don't know how to function Joe what was
it like reading the script for the very
first time because so much of this movie
really comes to life in the Edit and
seeing everything cut together so when
you're reading the screenplay are you
able to visualize what we wound up
getting at the end 100
yeah I feel like the screenplay read you
know although things are it's not
identical I don't think to the final
movie it read with a very similar pace I
think to watching the movie so I was
yeah I mean I was pretty hooked and kind
of shocked at the script and was
wondering how they're gonna pull certain
things off but mostly I felt that I had
sort of an understanding of who the who
Kurt was and I guess after meeting you
and talking to you about it briefly it
was but I felt at least that we were
sort of on the same page we were
wondering how we're gonna pull certain
things off - I also don't give to
several ways like it's like we're gonna
write this down I hope we can execute
this crazy thing like on the freeway or
whatever but um but no I mean like
really working with Joe here's we
brought it to life like I mean like we
did change stuff a lot and we figured
out who Curt was together we did I mean
Jean my co-writer and I like had ideas
and you know we're trying to find the
voice and clearly knew what was wrong
with Curt you know with his thinking and
the sort of a moral attitude towards
social media and whatever in life but
Joe really came on board and and made
him a real person and grounded him in
this sort of delusion and this naivete
and this very scary relatability and we
watched a lot of videos and we did made
a lot of prep videos and research videos
Oh like like YouTube livestream tae-bo
yeah that's a huge part of just the prep
for the movie is just making all it a
lot of the research was watching people
you know all these kind of want to be
influencers people like you've said for
every you know people there's you know a
hundred thousand people who've you never
heard of yeah who still are posting 20
times a week and have you know seven
followers did working on this movie make
you guys rethink how you use social
media because it's like the first thing
I did when I walked out of the theater
was check my Twitter feed and start
liking things I'm like oh and call an
uber problem see what's happening right
now yeah yeah I'm I think I think so I
think it but through the process of the
film I guess you know not necessarily
seeing the final film for myself but
just maybe going through the process I
think my own personal relationship to
social media is different
than Kurtz but it's maybe open my eyes
to that the fact that it's I guess there
are many more people you know who are
interacting with the social media that
way than the way that I'm seeing Kurtz
pop up all over the place which is very
scary
um did change my relationship to it like
I don't think so I mean that's part of
we the double-edged sword of you know
the world we live in right we can be
critical we can say we're going like
like Jessie Adams in the film is saying
like you know she's going off line or
whatever we can say that but ultimately
like if you exist now you're invariably
part of that ecosystem so like you know
and you have to make your peace with it
and like you know one thing I've thought
about a lot in relation to this film is
like something like you know dr.
Strangelove is like making fun of
nuclear holocaust which is truly like a
horrific existential crisis and we're
trying to take that approach toward
something social media but like those
nuclear bombs still exist like we're
still gonna wake up in the morning and
have those handles and those ways of the
world monitoring us and us you know
reacting back where do you find yourself
nailing the tone of the movie more in
the script and the prep process onset or
imposed I mean it's all about that final
product that you put out the final what
if they're a piece of art film whatever
that you put out into the world
everything else is just raw material
right like you know the script is a
blueprint and then Joe brings all this
great material and then you're editing
it and then you're doing pickups and
then you're like writing 8,000 comments
and all it's just for one final thing
which is Spri which is the movie right
and and it's really tricky because the
tone of the film is very complex and as
you know but I hope it's been awesome
seeing it with audiences because it's
been very validating because it feels it
really did nail it you know it's not an
exploitation film it is a film that has
a I think we're all on the right side of
history in terms of the social critique
of like the horrific stuff that's going
on in society 2020 oh that's not the
only impressive thing about the movie I
just can't even begin to wrap my mind
around how you guys shot this so can you
paint a picture of what the set would
look like especially when you're
shooting a significant amount in the car
is it just you know GoPros are in the
car and that's what you get I mean
that was something that was really
appealing but also signing on to the
project was the fact that you know we're
the way that we shot these rides were
really just you know they truly were
just unfolding I mean we set everything
up and I mean hats off to the crew in
Eugene because a lot of the technology
that you know you know these cameras
weren't designed to do a feature yeah
there's a lot we had to like adjust
later on but it's a little bit I think
like for what I know about jaws kind of
like shooting jaws or something where
like we were in a monitoring van and
then Joe's most of them actually driving
the car like on the roads and then the
actors are there and they're really
playing out the scene you know and then
I miss talking when a walkie and we have
monitors we had like you know sort of a
wireless monitors that we could if we
were close enough and weren't in frame
could actually see and hear everything
that was going on but I'm just kind of
tailing this like van but like also kind
of think far enough away so that the
debt the dashcam doesn't actually you
know capture it up a lot of the shots on
us if you're all the time so how about
how much of screen time are you shooting
in 100 30 minutes but we probably do
like you know three or four takes okay
kind of land these roots and drive the
roots and do the scene and then stop and
then drive the route and do this we plan
the 30 30 minute routes and then you'd
be like okay we know that he has to hit
this stop sign here and then we'd be
like okay we're two blocks away from the
stop sign so I get into that part of the
scene and Joe and the other actors were
just such professionals even though
there were doing so much improv they'd
know where those beats were and they'd
hit them faster based on where it's so
easy though because like it in term the
acting perspective it just totally takes
you out of your head because you're
you're worried about so many other
things you're worried about the driving
and then you know you don't really have
time over that can get exactly so I
think you know that was something that
was stressful I think maybe day one but
then at the end of day one just kind of
realizing that you know you can really
use this to you know help you through
the film and for the record all the
crazy stunts that people see maybe that
was all Joe he did all his own stunts
every [ __ ] thing
no actually shout-out to casey adams
awesome stunt court yes hell yeah so
what are some of the technical things
that you had to keep in mind though
during those performances especially
let's say getting you know four takes of
a 30-minute scene are you worried about
you know your eye line and making sure
whatever you're improving in one take
matches another take or any of those
things going through your head yeah I
think so you know there's a little
there's a there's a huge technical
element you know and that's something
that you always I don't know you always
have to deal with no matter what set
you're on some more than others but yeah
I mean luckily I guess you can maybe
speak to it more improv sort of matching
up that wasn't a hard thing to do you
were nailing it even though you were
changing things up but I also think
there is just a certain like even though
I think your relationship social media
is quite thoughtful and like detached
and like earnest but detached you
personally yeah I do think that we all
just as users of smartphones and social
media have a natural or a natural or
organic but have developed you know a
thoughtless or a relationship with our
phones and how they operate and what
what does it mean to look at your phone
right and so when Joe's doing Kurt and
he's like mugging it for the audience
right it's very similar to how you might
do a FaceTime with someone you know when
we think about eye lines in this film
and it's quite different than another
film because it's built in meta
awareness of his character to the
audience interaction which was fun I
mean really fun like that that's why all
those like there are certain moments in
the film where you know you can give
like looks to the cameras and that's
part of the critique implicating the
audience and what they're watching you
know so random but I'm always fascinated
by hearing how a filmmaker comes up with
the names and huncle's one that's going
to stick with me so what made you settle
on that well we I had a first second
Kirk crinkle I remember Curt crinkle and
then we changed it for some reasons and
then it's just like sounds like short
hard and kind of like garbage you know
it's just it's like no offense they
might have the name but it's just like
short hard and harsh it's like more gobo
marbles in your mouth or something you
know it's like a it's like it's almost
like a machine breaking and that is
actually I think a way think about a
Kurt's mind right getting fed all
of this like crap from being created by
social media it's like the his brain
machine has broken you know that's what
Kurt Kunkel sounds like to me ya know
that's a that's a pretty good
description right there without going
into spoiler territory I am curious what
was the most challenging scene for you
guys to pull off because there there's
there's quite a few that come to mind
there's there's no I don't know if it's
the most challenging but there are
moments for different actors me included
how to use a body cam and that's kind of
difficult because you're technically you
know you're like a tripod for this thing
and you're you're having to frame up all
these different actors without even
really looking at a monitor so there's
this thing mounted on you like there's a
scene in a club where I have to know
Walker and also Josh as well has to do
it that was pretty tough technically
like Bobby the influencer yeah I don't
know if that was the most challenging
but that was a definitely difficult
element we invented our own workflow for
the film's like like we said before it's
these dash cams and GoPros and body cams
and iPhones not made for a feature film
making so it's like every day was a new
challenge but it was fun
the crew was up to the challenge the
cast which was operating the phones and
the body cams was very up to the
challenge and I felt like that's a fun
of filmmaking right every obstacle
becomes an opportunity and when you
limit your film language that's when you
create so like I like that it's really
truly out of the limitations comes you
know something that yes endlessly
fascinated by the screen life format and
how that's changing storytelling in all
formats right now so that is something
you guys do extremely thanks very much
I've been trying to get for a long time
my first movie is a screen movie from
2010 it's called zeros and ones and it's
all like told through operating systems
they have apps and games and phones
popping up and comments pockets so did
this feel like you know a little bit
like 2.0 and then while I made that I
made a Skype movie that was all Gigi
chat videos and Skype chats that was all
captured like an easy version have you
ever talked to a timur bekmambetov yeah
well I've had conversations and a lot of
people who worked on my films worked on
I loved yes the kind of stuff anything
is bad I think it's really important
that filmmakers push forward film
language and acknowledge what's going on
in our day to day lives did you write
all the comments that we see yeah I'll I
was paying very close attention to it
and they they all have values so I
imagined you guys sitting there and
right now yeah lucky to have a few
friends sometimes in a lot of time it
was just me and there's over 8,000
comments in the film with unique
usernames that have to do explicitly of
what's going on and we so I sort of
watch a scene again and again again and
be like what's funny for this moment
what's disturbing for this moment what's
twitch like for this moment and do it
I'm glad it seems like people really dig
that it works it works very well I am
curious about what you're thinking in
terms of distribution for this and I
know that's a tough thing to talk about
when you're probably working to get that
right now but you know where do you want
this film to live to screen life's a
different thing where I can understand
if you have the intentions of having it
screen on the big screen but it's also
something that could easily live on the
computer and also going after that
particular audience it feels like I
don't know a very appropriate thing to
reach the max of Gen Z on streaming yeah
yeah I mean like I think movie like this
I don't get ahead of myself yeah but
like you know I've seen it with three
audiences now I would say different
types of audiences you know like a
midnight screening a screening outside
of Park City situation and like kind of
the opening night screening and the
reaction has been on the big screen
really great you know
like watching with a bunch of people you
just get all the gasps and all the
laughs at the same time so I think just
whatever helps us reach the biggest
possible audience they can see Joe's
amazing performance and so they can be
overwhelmed by the cinematic nature of
the film is really important to me so
and also you're just having a impactful
conversation and discourse in the
culture you know so I think as many
people as possible that could see the
film would be the best distribution I
feel like there has to be some sort of
scenario where you can live stream the
film so the viewers can interact as I
don't know I'm just my mind spinning out
of control with the possibilities by the
way I'm at P number off on Twitter
follow you but I'm written for you guys
though thanks very much I have to let
you go thank you guys so much
the process of making this movie all day
long I'm fascinated very impressed
thanks for gradually spree keep an eye
out for it thank you guys so much for
watching this interview like and share
it but I feel so weird say yeah like
[ __ ] before you bash that subscribe
button thank you to our sponsor Kia for
making all this stuff happen at the
supper suite in Park City we'll see you
guys soon with more coverage from the
festival